normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government ladies
and gentlemen huge news right now 8:45
p.m. breaking Henry Kissinger who shaped
world affairs under two presidents dies
at
100 if we're on the members only show
I'd have a lot more to say but uh we'll
save it for the members only show I I
have a special special statement for
everybody um when we start the members
only show but for now we'll keep it
professional so uh you were saying no I
was going to say there was an interview
that he gave
recently um you know kind of on the
heels of one of these Summits where he
was kind of you could tell that he was
he was sort of like on the way out um in
the interview itself and you could see
him being very self-critical in this
interview and you know let's let's keep
in mind that for all of his work during
the Cold War um this was also a guy who
was one of the main architects of
globalism and the current system of that
globalism and you know he came out and
basically said you know maybe we got it
wrong and maybe we shouldn't have pushed
for all of this open border stuff maybe
we shouldn't have pushed for this
migration stuff maybe we should have
realized that countries do have security
concerns and the John Mir schimers of
the world or he didn't say all this but
it's clearly what he was he was
referring to because you could see that
he was reflecting I think on the and I
remember I was in I was at Davos where
um in 2022 where Kissinger came up and
gave this huge speech blaming the
blaming NATO for the um NATO expansion
on the war in Ukraine and it was
suddenly like wait kisinger of all
people is coming out saying these things
and it's almost like you know it's like
towards the end as as he can see the
light fading you know him kind of going
back and and maybe re reexamining some
of his steps and realizing that they
probably weren't the best moves you know
you know the meme where it's uh death
playing the crane game the first thing
that popped in my head and he keeps
going literally the first thing that
popped in my head you know he's like nor
McDonald is Henry ker even even in this
thing well now someone can finally make
it of him just going Kissinger got him
that's it so what do you think Norm's
gonna say to Kissinger when they
meet dude I can't believe it this guy
was so evil man Henry Kissinger a
scholar a Statesman and celebrity
Diplomat who wielded unparalleled power
over US foreign policy throughout the
administrations of Nick and Gerald Ford
who for decades afterward and a
consultant and writer proferred opinions
that shaped global politics and business
died November 29th at his home in
Connecticut he was 100 look I never like
celebrating death you know people dying
is always bad I wish he wasn't such a
nasty nasty guy I can say however
regardless of however you feel about it
the world will will be better off
unfortunately I I'm trying to be very
nice but there's just some people I
cannot you he's a he's a bad guy he's a
very very bad guy there's this tic he's
got quotes that will that will make you
throw up this dude yeah there's this
article from Indie 100 that says the is
Henry Kissinger dead Twitter account is
tired of waiting for him to die this is
from 2022 and they were like we didn't
think this would be such a long-term
commitment which I think is kind of
funny I think there were a lot of people
who were uh not expecting this but I
don't know he uh here it is is Henry
kiss did Kissinger die minutes ago and
uh no no still no and then 10 minutes
ago yes already up to 12,000 retweets
and he's been doing it for 2 years wild
man wow there you look dude he's an
architect for so much foreign policy
garbage foreign intervention nation
building disgusting racist comments I
mean this dude is just I I could not
imagine a you know when I look at these
serial killers and these really evil
nasty people who do really evil things
I'm like yeah that's There's real evil
in this world when I look at k Dr like
but he was smarter about how he went
about the the awful things he did so he
could maintain power while he did it mhm
look I mean see you got a guy who came
up with and it executed the theory of
reproach M with communist China with
chairman Mau right so he flies over
because remember people don't realize
this that somebody went over yeah
there's the meme finally oh there it is
so people know that Nixon went over to
you know kind of open up China Nixon
goes to China and this is what peels
China away from the Soviet Union and
eventually leads to you know winning the
war well ker Not only was the architect
kinger actually went there first and met
with Joe and Li in a secret trip that
nobody knew about to kind of pave the
way for Nixon going there and so you
know Tim to your point you know it it
takes a very
cold you know like just just unemotional
unfeeling mind to come up with the idea
of yeah I'm going to sit down with
chairman ma the you know probably one of
the most most murderous men to ever walk
the face of the Earth but it's going to
help us politically cuz they they look
at us like chickens we are just chickens
to lay eggs for them to harvest so
they're not thinking about you and your
family the pain and suffering you go
through they don't care about what
happens to your friends who who died
mysteriously in their sleep they don't
they don't want to answer any of those
questions and they don't care that's why
these people are disgusting and evil
these are the the sociopaths who who
fight for political power G political
power and this is the corruption we need
to weed out of our government and we can
we can do it and I think we're winning
and I'm and I'm happy to see it every
day there are more and more victories
and every day there are more and more
signs that we are headed towards
something better yeah so I'm I'm I'm I'm
glad again I don't I don't I don't like
ever no matter who it is having a
celebration of some death because the
reality is the dude should have been a
better person you know life is precious
even even someone as awful as him but
you have to recognize sometimes there
are people that cause too too much
destruction and so at the very least we
can be like well I'm not Trum I'm not
going to cheer for his death but I am
going to be like the world is going to
be better off without his foreign policy
ideas and and and all that yeah but the
legacy of anything is still there right
even if he's dead the impact of the
decisions he made will feel it's true
but I'm hoping we get a good trumpian
statement where he was like sad day
hearing Henry Kissinger died he was a
great man who did atrocious things and
evil and you know and he never support
well knowing Trump would be like and he
never supported
me he he never once came in you know and
uh and my my favorite all-time one of of
trump responding to someone's death
which of of course obviously the the RBG
one is now just just it has become its
own thing um it's it's actually
overshadowed anything that Ruth Bader
Ginsburg did in her entire life is
Trump's reaction to the news of her
death and um but there's the right after
Trump got elected and and Tim as you say
sort of the the psychic energy um you
know as young called it the um uh the uh
the the world Spirit you know this this
idea that that you know the um what's
the What's The Phrase the unconscious
the collective unconscious colletive
unconscious that he is my fourth show of
the day um that um when Trump is right
after he was elected before he was
inaugurated Castro dies and then
everyone's you know coming to him like
Oh Mr you know pres Mr president-elect
uh Castro's dead he's he's passed away
finally he like want to come up with a
formal statement and you know put out
something you know very magnanimous as
the president and Trump just picks up
Twitter and goes Fidel Castro is dead
yeah I was gonna ask wasn't kinger just
in China recently I feel like he was I
just saw news be like a couple days how
could he possibly be in China he's 100
years old yeah there was something about
him I read ghost is there does anyone I
don't recall he could have been at the
oan
summit AC yeah which was in San
Francisco uh I saw that he was in China
I don't remember what it was exactly but
he had something to do with he traveled
back and forth so he set up a foreign
policy a l that was very July 2020 uh
July 22nd 2023 I foret what it was but I
saw him in the news a while ago I don't
remember what it was he's been he's been
going back and forth to China ever since
the for a long time yeah for he was
first and he he kept doing it over and
over and over and so I mean if you want
to talk about someone who's been you
know just just at the Forefront of the
US China relationship
since it began in the modern era with
with chairman Mau and the Chinese
Communist party that's that's Henry ker
and you know obviously someone who you
know and I I'm I'm going to be actually
flying to Japan tomorrow so I'm speaking
at um CAC Tokyo on Saturday so you know
I'm sure this will be kind of cast a you
know a different angle on on a lot of
the topics that we discussed because you
know when we're really looking at the
system that we have now the
relationships even the the multilateral
alliances that the United States has in
East Asia the security alliances you
know it really was Kissinger who played
a huge part in setting this all up I
just messaged
Cassandra she was like what's going on
what did I miss and then she just said I
just the people who hate War are like
wow well I I you know trying to be very
professional the people who hate War are
probably jumping up and down dancing on
their tables right now why because
people I heard the reverse thing the
tank the tank
hate War the tankes went like full all
right it's it's past n The Voice
probably tankies are like fully orgasmic
right now fully fully yeah that's wild
man you know seeing Trump win was we
were talking about this earlier actually
what everybody remembers the day
everyone remembers where they were when
Trump won M it was wild right we were
talking about that yeah everybody was
crying I was hanging out with Cassandra
and uh Cassandra was crying but she was
crying for a different reason she was
crying tears of joy everyone else in the
room was like sitting there covered in
sweat and a bunch of them were were
legit balling it it it was wild for me
to see adults cry over an election like
this I thought I was laughing I mean cuz
the thing too is it's like we've been
through a number of Elections and it's
like okay now we have a different
president I wonder how this one's going
to go yeah you know I remember talking
to people in the theater community at
the time and everyone was miserable and
they were crying and they were sad and
they thought it was literally the end of
the world and I was like well why don't
we wait and see what he does you know
anything's possible like anything's yeah
but they're all bad I
mean specific like fear and hatred
whipped up was bad Bush was bad I mean
this is like what I remember I think I
was living no I wasn't living K when
when uh I was at still in Texas when
Trump got elected and so there were
people I was in college and there were
people who were so excited remember one
of the fraternities got in trouble for
hanging a like Trump 2016 Banner out of
their door they had to like take it down
I got a fine or something then there was
like all of these different like you
know social justice organizations being
like we stand together they will not
divide us whatever they they were
allowed to do whatever they wanted I
mean there was a complete divide in
hysteria because it was it was totally
buil on the emotions of these people who
felt as though their lives personally
were as if Donald Trump would come down
their chimney and personally had first
gay Cabinet member yes M
like right I I don't know that there is
anyone who was afraid of trump in 2016
who had accurate information on I mean I
was I was up in New York I was at the
party that was was pretty baller that
was uh that was definitely one of the
best nights I was at the Sputnik office
because that's where Cassandra had
worked at the time and and the the they
kept saying that Russia was supporting
Trump and I'm like dude everybody in
this building was for Hillary and when
Trump won they were losing it it was
wild that night I just never forget when
the New York Times had that probability
meter that was like 90 greater than 99%
for Hillary and it slowly started to
move I remember when it hit 50% and
people started being like no no
Cassandra sitting there like oh oh my
God oh my God and then I remember when
it was greater than 99 for Trump and
there was a lot of crying but candre was
the only one crying tears of joy yeah I
remember watching it at like whatever
after midnight like someone some like
Democrat I was being like well but
Pennsylvania maybe and everyone else is
like no it's over like it's over so that
that night I that day i' had been
working and doing live streams all
around
Philadelphia and actually ran into James
O'Keefe at one point um uh like a funny
story about that maybe we'll reveal it
sometime um but now that well I I'd want
to talk to James first if it's so funny
just tell us live right now well because
he was in the middle of doing one of the
things so I don't want to you know I
don't want to break his opsac so I'm not
going to do that but the uh I'm a middle
child what can you know we realized that
I remember I was driving around looking
for the different so like the afterwork
rush in Philly so that was when you
would really get your major Philadelphia
vote out would always come in the
afterwork rush so usually when people uh
vote on Election Day you get you know it
comes in three tranches this is before
this is like when we actually have like
real elections not like the crazy time
the crazy Gaga that we have now uh that
we call an election which is really just
a ballot kind of Phil you're pull you're
pulling the levers pulling the so so
this is um you know early morning so
pre-work uh then lunchtime then there's
a huge Deadtime and then there's the
afterwork rush the afterwork rush never
came I went to North Philly I went to
West Philly I went to South Philly just
never happened and I said Philadelphia
doesn't have a rush Trump's going to win
Pennsylvania Trump wins Pennsylvania
he's going to be the president so I
drove 30th Street Station bought a
ticket right on the right uh right at
the at the spot or on the spot up to New
York straight to the party thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podc hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net